الثانيه مع مراسلي صباح العربيه هذه المره
مع احلام العبدلي بعد غياب 50 عام بنات
الفا يمثل تونس في مهرجان كان هذا الفيلم
خلينا نسال احلام
طيب
صباح النور
صباح الخير بالفعل صباح الانوار صباح
الخير على
فكره بعد غياب اكثر من خمسين سنه يعيشك
بعد غياب اكثر من خمسين سنه تحديدا 53 سنه
منذ اخر مشاركه في اكبر تظاهره سينمائيه
في فرنسا واحدى اكبر تظاهرات في العالم
مهرجان كان الدولي كوثر بن هنيه التونسيه
بفريق نسائي بحث تذهب وتتنافس على السعفه
الذهبيه احدى اغلى الالقاب
السينمائيه العالميه التي تعتبر ربما لحظه
فارقه في تاريخ السينما التونسيه بعد غياب
خمسه عقود فريق نسائي قلت تتصدره النجمه
التونسيه هند صبري في فيلم بنات الفه الذي
هو في الحقيقه ودون ان نحرق احداث الفيلم
مؤكد بانه سوف يحدث الكثير والكثير بناء
الضجه وسوف يسيل الحبر هو قصه واقعيه
تونسيه وابطالها الحقيقيون موجودون داخل
هذا الفيلم ويشاركون في التمثيل
خلاص شكرا جزيلا لك احلام للاسف مش وقت
كتير اليوم اكيد رح تكوني معنا في الايام
القادمه بمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات